Richard Dean Anderson returning to
Stargate is it still possible welcome to
Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and movie
channel
if you're gonna go ahead with it
I want to make sure you get one thing
right
O'Neill
with two L's
there's another Colonel O'Neal with only
one L he has no sense of humor at all
[Music]
first of all I'm just going to say I've
got a bit of a cold so excuse me but um
I just wanted to talk about Richard Dean
Anderson and his possible return to
Stargate now
Richard Dean Anderson first of all I was
going to say he is in his 70s damn good
to see you again
don't worry
aside from a little prostate problem we
won't go into
it's not so bad
he actually stepped away from Stargate
to begin with because he wanted to spend
more time with his family and more time
on his charity work you know I'm kind of
partial to p3575 if you don't mind
taking p38577 no I'll take five seconds
how about you go where I took it really
is a big campaigner and particularly in
cleaning up the oceans and protecting
the oceans and generally environmental
campaigning now we also know that
Richard Dean Anderson
put on a bit of weight he actually put
on a lot of weight and I have to say as
well there have been lots of rumors
about his health particularly two or
three years ago that you know he was
quite unwell once or twice now I don't
want to get into his personal life he's
a very private person so I don't want to
say any more than that but it does seem
to be losing weight significantly now I
actually said to you over a year ago
there was rumors even when we knew
nothing about Brad Wright's script that
Richard Dean Anderson would return and
that Brad Wright was very keen for him
to now it's been confirmed since through
Brad right and through sources I speak
to the Richard Dean Anderson had
verbally agreed to return in a cameo for
at very least the first couple of
episodes of any new Stargate series Brad
Wright did what's the alternative
now Richard Dean Anderson has done the
companion with Brad Wright a couple of
times doing these interviews and then
actually doing these AI generated script
they seem to have a lot of fun doing it
very recently as well just in the last
couple of weeks Richard Dean Anderson
did do the Paris Comic Con and actually
appeared with Samantha Carter his
on-screen wife I'm under tapping they
seem to have had an awful lot of fun
they had a lot of cheeky questions and
they were asked would they return and
they both basically said if you do oh
well now the rumor I heard was actually
that these big motivation for losing
weight was that he thoroughly expected
Brad right script to get made and for
him to appear in that but does that mean
that he could still appear in any new
star game well we know Brad Wright's
script is no longer getting made we also
now know that Amazon have been looking
for a production company to produce a
new Stargate series and been asking
companies to pitch their ideas to them
but
through the people I speak to I also get
little Snippets of information about
what's going on at Amazon and one of the
things that I was told very recently is
that as part of the development process
the marketing and sort of like a
strategy team that if we were to bring
back some actors from the original
series which ones would be most popular
with the Gators now I'm going to say
initially I'm a little bit cynical about
this I actually genuinely believe Amazon
are going to do sort of a Star Trek
Style
semi-reboot with Stargate I keep calling
it a hybrid reboot where Canon is still
there but they're allowed to pick and
choose from it a little bit that Amazon
will allow and MGM will allow the new
creators of Stargate some creative
license to change bits and Bobs along
the way
but a way to appease fans if you do that
is to bring back a couple of actors from
The Original Series in cameos and to
reference Canon as um every so often to
you know so the Gators sort of go oh I
remember that I remember that and it
sort of keeps us happy
now it's a little bit of a cynical
tactic but it's a tactic that they use
very well in Star Trek or the new track
we've seen at the moment don't forget to
like subscribe and hit the Bell
notification so you don't miss any of
our new videos and also if you want to
become a fully fledged side tracker and
you want to really support the channel
consider hitting the join button
foreign
so on that list RDA apparently came top
Richard Dean Anderson would be the most
popular actor to return to Stargate now
we know that Amazon about six to nine
months ago did several surveys asking
people what they like about Stargate and
what they would like to see if a new
Stargate came out they sent these
surveys to a very limited number of
Amazon customers
we also know that Amazon spent an awful
lot of time looking at things like
metadata and clicks on YouTube videos
they look at you clicks on stories about
it they look how many times the actors
names are mentioned in reports you know
like articles and things like this and
they brought all that information
together they did a bunch of very pretty
graphs apparently and as I say Richard
Dean Anderson's name came top now I know
that doesn't mean that Richard Dean
Anderson is going to be in any new
Stargate series all it means is Amazon
have identified him as the most valuable
person to return in any new Stargate
Series so if we only brought in one
Cameo and that Cameo was Richard Dean
Anderson he would have the most impact
with Gator fans now we also know that
actually now we do know that Richard
Nelson was planned and was actually
scripted into at least one or two
versions of the Brad Wright script
um Brad apparently there's a line in
there that he said to some other Carter
something about I've still got your
toothbrush or something along those
lines which obviously then suggested
that they'd been in a relationship and
whatever else now right now we have no
clue about what any new creator of
Stargate might do as far as we know
there are no scripts as far as we know
the development is really only just
begun and they only have very vague
outlines of what they would like to do
with the series or movies but it does
seem very clear that Amazon are very
keen to bring back a few actors at least
in cameos from the additional series I
do think it's important that any new TV
series or movie has some connection back
to the originals it's been a 16-year gap
now since SGU left their screens and any
new TV show has to explain that time Gap
and having an actor or a few actors from
the original series really gives writers
that opportunity and that doorway into
explaining that time Gap
so what do I think do I think Richard
Anderson could return for a cameo well
he was going to he still goes to
Stargate conventions and things he still
talks very fondly about Stargate he does
seem to be getting back out there again
after a quite a long period of not
really wanting to be in the Limelight
not really wanting to speak to anybody
particularly of just wanting to focus on
his charity stuff so is he going to
return in the new Stargate series I
think it would very much depend on who
Amazon finally pick to do the project
what the script was as long as the stars
align it would seem that Amazon would be
very interested in having Richard Dean
Anderson come back to Stargate
but guys again with the comments tell me
what you think you can tell me how bad
my voice is and oh bunged up I obviously
am or we could talk about Stargate tell
us exactly what you think about the
possibility of Richard Dean Anderson
returning and if you had a list of the
top actors you'd like to return to
Stargate franchise would Richard Dean
Amsterdam be at the top of that list who
would be second and I mentioned who came
in second because I actually know who
did come in second on this list Amanda
Tapping was third Michael Shanks was
fourth Jason Momoa was Fifth and
um Dave Hewlett
um McKay was sixth
um but the person that came in second
was actually a quite a big shock to me
and if they were to bring in this person
I think a lot of fans would be very very
excited not necessarily for the actor
but what him returning to Stargate would
mean
but I'm going to tell you about that in
another video if you are new to the
Channel please like subscribe hit that
Bell notification so you don't miss any
of our new videos and if you really want
to support the channel consider hitting
the join Button as always guys please
stay safe and I'll see you next time
[Music]